こんにちは。
自宅警備員はじめしゃちょーです。
おまえら
命の危険を感じたことはないか
今は世界の何処に居ても...
カタッ　　カタカタカカタ
なんでこんなガタガタする?
あれ?
今は地球のどこに居ても、いつ、誰が襲いかかって来ても分らない
ネットワーク社会になりつつある。
今の現代において、少しの命取りがとんでもない悲劇を巻き起こす事があるんだ。
そこで私は、もし、もし仮に俺の家に、僕を殺そうとする暗殺者が入って来た時に、いかにして戦うか
おそらくなんですけども、僕多分そんなに戦闘力ないんで
マジ、悪者が来たらシンプルに多分普通にやられて終わります。
ありがとうございました。
なので、ここはちょっとね、知恵を働かして
戦うんじゃなくて、隠れようかと思いまして
もし自宅にヤバいやつが入り込んだ時に、僕はいかにして隠れるかと言う事を考えた時
段ボールを利用、段ボール・・・
段ボール・・・
めっちゃｋ・・・言えないわ
段ボールを利用しようかなと思いまして
今回は段ボールを利用した、ステレス・ルームの作り方を皆さんにご紹介しようと思います。
自宅警備員のみんな！カモン!!
わかると思うんですけど、大量の段ボールが準備してある。
私は今からここにある段ボールを全部四角にしてこの部屋全体を段ボール箱で埋め尽くします。
たぶんね、やばい量があるんですよ。
もうすぐ襲撃者がくるので襲撃者に僕がこの段ボールステレス・ルームにいったらばれないかどうかというね
今回はちょっと緊急時の命にかかわる大事な訓練です。
もうばれたら終わったぐらいの勢いでマジでやるんで
では、作っていこう
まってこれ、、、まってこれ、ちょーめんどくさいやつじゃない
まってこれ、ちょーめんどくさいやつじゃん
うわーもうやばい、間に合うかな
こ～の高さよ、、、
もうちょっとあるんでもうちょっと積みます
はい、というわけで完成、、
はい、というわけで完成しました
これが段ボールステレス・ルームです
どうだこのかんぷ、、、あっ、これはなんでもないっす
どうだこのかんぷなきまでに埋め尽くした段ボール！！
これはきたでしょー！！
後ろも全部段ボールでございます
はい、というわけでこれからターゲットが来るんですけども
もうやるかやられるかの一機勝負
見つかった瞬間、僕はもう、、、
なのでちょっとね本当にかなり僕は本気でやります
もうすぐターゲットが来るので僕はこの段ボールの中のどれかに入っています。
３分ぐらいかな？
３分以内に見つかれば僕はもうThe end
３分間生き残れれば僕の勝ちです。
今まで使ってきた段ボール企画で一番量が多いです、この段ボール。
僕がこれまで捨てずにとっといた段ボール全部です。
果たして僕を見つけることができるのでしょうか
では、
はい、というわけでもうすぐ来ると思うので
僕は段ボールに隠れます。
えっ、どうしよどうしよう
まって、どこに隠れればいいんだろう、、、
隠れる場所がわからん
まず、どう隠れるし、、、
ひとまず奥に行きましょう
簡単につかまるわけにはいかねーからな
俺も相手も命懸けだ
やるかやられるかの一騎打ち
ひるんでらんねーぜ
よし、ここにします！
うわーびっくりしたー！！
いなくねー？！
というわけで、ステレス、、段ボールステレス・ルームでした（笑）